President Trump was given a fresh reason
today to call for the end of the special
counsels investigation
the republican-led house Intel committee
released its final report today that
found no evidence of conspiracy or
collusion between Russia and the Trump
team well the president just tweeted at
the top of the hour the House
Intelligence Committee rules that there
was no collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russia as I've been saying
all along it is all a big hoax by the
Democrats based on payments and lies
there should be should never have been a
special council appointed witch-hunt but
Democrats just can't let go I think it's
just a gloss on a very political report
document that could have been written by
the White House said close the
investigation and write such an
inaccurate incomplete and irresponsibly
premature report does nothing to protect
us this complete partisan whitewash by
the Republicans on the Intelligence
Committee just shows more so why we need
an honest report in many ways it was a
kind of kindergarten investigation
joining me now for reactions Republican
congressman Sean Duffy in Wisconsin and
radio talk show host Lesley Marshall in
LA great to see both of you congressman
Duffy the president was all over this
tonight I mean he's tweeting about it he
said it basically it's time to end this
Russian investigation Jeff session said
as much this week as well but you're the
Democrats like you guys said just it's
all political there's there's no serious
examination of these issues and they're
not letting this go so if the Democrats
Laura maybe we could cube Jack Nicholson
from a few good man and he could say you
can't handle the truth Democrats will
never absorb the truth that there was no
Russia collusion when to take a step
back down memory lane Dan fine stand a
Democrat senator from California who is
the head of the Democrats for the Senate
Intelligence Committee and both James
clapper who worked for Barack Obama for
his National Intelligence Committee both
have said they've seen no evidence of
collusion what this is about is very
simple
Democrats don't look for the truth this
is all about politics if you don't have
the Russian narrative and the Russia
occlusion story you might have to talk
about Korea and what happened today you
might have to talk about Donald Trump
crushing Isis you might have to talk
about GDP growth and job growth and wage
growth in a secure border and the fact
that were energy independent Democrats
can't talk about those things and that's
why they have to stick on this narrative
of Russia collusion otherwise they can't
run on anything this this coming
November election so this is about
politics not truth
Leslie Oh congressman with all due
respect we can multitask we Democrats
but no this is not this is Paula this is
political and it is partisan because
when you look at this committee it's not
the bipartisan committee that has said
okay no collusion it is the Republicans
there's still a Senate committee and we
still have an independent council by
robert muller and I say Democrats and
Republicans back off and let the guy do
his job if in fact there is no collusion
we need to find that out this committee
has not interviewed the people that
Moeller has interviewed this committee
has not looked into all the
documentation that the Independent
Counsel has before him so this does not
give an exoneration to the president at
all this is some Republicans saying they
based on what we looked into and they
didn't look into everything we don't
feel there's an issue here one more
thing about James gobbler this
investigation would never stop for
Democrats I mean no matter how much
evidence comes out no matter how clear
it is that Donald Trump won by the force
of his ideas in the force of his
personality in the outworlds Hillary
Clinton that's why he won Democrats
can't handle that when will you accept
it how much evidence do you need how
much information do you need to show
that Donald Trump had a hard time
cluding with Republicans let alone
trying to clued with Russians I mean
when do you accept it let me let me jump
in here guys because yes Leslie I think
the one thing that congressman Duffy
mentioned was this interesting tidbit
that I guess now has been confirmed that
former Dianne Feinstein staffer daniel
Jones in the 2016 campaign was the
person responsible for getting that
fusion GPS Christopher steel dossier
going
which is interesting because obviously
feinstein is a important Senate figure
herself but it just reinforces this idea
that this was a political hit job from
the beginning it was Oppo research
pushed through this
Christopher Steele who later got you
know was disassociated from the FBI for
leaking information to the media that
was an interesting tidbit Democrats kind
of brushed that off early on but it was
now confirmed I don't have a problem
with the confirmation of this because of
the time line he was working for the
senator in 2015 and that's when he left
he worked with her prior to that and
then it was after the election that he
with his organization and money from
private donors hired tried to hire mr.
Steele and Fusion GPS I don't have a
problem with that because of the
timeline there what what was his motive
I mean clearly it was political do we
see any corroboration anything in
writing from mr. Steele we don't we have
emails and conversations that Allsteel
told me this etc but I I don't have a
problem jus to the timeline yeah well of
course she does it but this they raised
fifty million dollars from ten donors
from New York and California to drive
the narrative of the rush occlusion
story and the phony dossier well I
thought Democrats proposed to dirty
money and dark money and politics
they're only opposed to it if it helps
Republicans but if it helps them they
love dark money as Leslie just said I
mean this was 50 million dollars to
promote this story from big donors
alright guys fantastic conversation
thanks to both of you tonight